all right so I want to kind of jump off
what you were talking about and I want
to go around and ask people like why do
you think that the rate of single
mothers has gone up like who like what
is the cause of it what do you think is
causing so many women to end up being
you know without a man there in the
house
oh no no let's go around
okay that's a very good question
um
um and it's a tough one but I do think
us woman we tend to create sort of an
illusion
and kind of fall in love with it like a
future image
and not really realize that we are not
with the right partner before we
actually get a kid
and
I think people end up being single first
of all because when they have a child it
changes both people
so I can absolutely relate for
for Auntie when she was saying that she
had the kids and then obviously his
partner was very abusive and so they
have to break up just to be sure that
it's gonna be better for everyone but
it's not it basically she cannot
necessarily see and I don't mean to be
um offensive or anything but she not
necessarily can see that science
beforehand because when you have a kid
it changes everything so I think that's
also one of the reason why there are so
many single womans with the kid because
they either do it too soon like they
think they might can have a kid because
they are in that moment in love and they
think yeah you know let's have a kid
because it would be fun some people do
it for money like in my country uh you
get like a really big amount of benefit
if you have a kid and the more you have
the more money you get and people don't
actually think in the future that you
just loaded in depth because you have to
pay that back oh no I want to jump on
what you said initially and you said um
women see like a certain like fairy tale
image of the guy most of them before
like it gets serious and then the guy
ends up actually showing his true colors
because in my opinion I feel like women
are really bad at choosing men like
consistently make poor choices in men in
in the first place you know what I'm
saying and then you know whatever re
whatever it is that attracted the woman
to the man should kind of hold on to
that no no regardless of red flags you
know what I'm saying then maybe she
might feel like oh I can have kid with
him make things gonna change because
he's gonna try to keep him he's the guy
I like blah blah blah and yeah obviously
it's not going to get better he's
actually going to always consistently
gonna get worse you're gonna say so it
might my take on things with the whole
single mother epidemic and I'm still
going to go around and get everyone's
opinion but I feel like it's a lot of
times a lot of the times that modern
women make bad choices in men do you get
what I'm saying and then obviously
coupled up with that a lot of us came
from single parent households as well do
you get what I'm saying so
um a lot of women they they have never
experienced a man who's given them
unconditional love and not expected
anything sexual back they go out in the
world they look for a father figure in
the guy that they're dating the the guy
is just being a guy yeah do you get what
I'm saying and then that's it there you
go you know what I'm saying so yeah what
do you think I think that's partly an
issue what's going on on social media
currently is that they like some
people they like even in general social
media trying to send a message that puts
into woman's brain what are the
qualities that you should look for like
what is the quote-unquote qualities you
should look for in a man before you
actually have a kid with a guy so what
I'm trying to say is um and I do
apologize that English is my second
language so if anything doesn't make
sense that's the reason
um but I do believe that women tend to
choose really wrong
um I mean obviously I cannot really
speak from that experience because I
just come out from an eight years
relationship and I do believe that I
choose the person really well and I
picked the right guy
and I know probably many people would
think so if he's the right guy why what
happened I know you're gonna go there so
the thing is what I can relate to is
that people change and I didn't mean to
be the one that changes with the kid on
my side like realize that I changed if
that makes sense like uh how should I
say so when when I met with my partner I
was 18 years old right and going back to
your very first question how is it
growing up without a father I actually
grew up without actually a role model of
mother so I'm coming from
basically just coming completely alone
because I fell in love I moved to London
and I met with my partner long story
short
um I came here because of him I was with
him for eight years but because I was so
young and so
unexperienced in life and in work and in
in every way
um I have to say that throughout the
eight years I changed a lot and I
realized that I changed mentally I
changed as a person so I didn't want it
to settle down
because we somehow just went into
different directions so that's that's
basically how I could explain that even
though you know that he's the right
person but there are just some own
personal changes in yourself so it just
depends on how mature we are to make
that decision
I think no yeah no definitely definitely
uh can I ask how old do you know you can
I remember I'm 26 26. yeah okay you're
not in the dangers oh you're kind of in
the danger zone but anyway
she said about
relating to me
you can't relate to me because she fell
in love
she was 18 she full enough
I had my son when I was 17 I didn't feel
enough I didn't fall enough I didn't
have no choice that's a difference all
right let me ask you this question I
would put it this far I'd say hang on a
minute I will put it in this part of
saying that I was groomed
that's why I said if you forget about I
said if my dad was there it wouldn't
have happened if my dad was there I
wasn't in love
and like I said to him when you're on a
Flats you're 10 stories up and the only
way out is over
that is not love I was never in love I
was in that position to be in love and
that's why I'm saying if my dad was
there it would have prevented it so it's
not like oh I was young and I met this
guy and I fell in love no yeah but it
goes back to what I said in addition
when I said well a lot of these girls
grow up and they don't have their dad
this is exactly yeah that's what I'm
saying to you you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah it was two different it's too
it's the same thing
it's a different outcome but the same
thing you you will need fathers but for
different reasons but for different
reasons I wasn't in love well I'm being
one thing I would say auntie the age
thing does play a factor the way it
sounded before because I didn't know the
age was your son at seven yeah I thought
you was a woman in your 20s and you're
trying to absolve yourself of
responsibility
so that's why I've only got one son I
hear it I put myself in there plus I was
on the pill as well and I wouldn't put
myself in that position so I've got none
all right cool we've we've ironed that
up
next so um what do you think about it
like what's causing all these single
mothers that like you know
nowadays we've uh normalized hookup
culture and situation ships over a more
formal courting in the past when you
have kids you have a proper committed
relationship and then you get married
and then you decide to have kids when
you know for sure that you have your
person and that you're both financially
stable nowadays with dating apps and
hookup culture and how you know people
have normalized how easy it is
a lot of it comes down to people being
irresponsible and having a kid by
accident
hold on hold on can I say one thing yeah
with that
um really and truly who who's being more
irresponsible in that situation because
there's a thing called the 80 20 rule
right eight yeah 80 of women are going
for the top 20 it's actually more 90 10
these days thanks to social media so the
majority of women are going for that top
10 whether it's by his Aesthetics his
looks money status clout whatever
whatever it is so who's really being
more irresponsible in this current day
and age is it the men or the women
because the majority of men are not
really getting play like that right so I
would have to say
um I'm not being misogynistic but I
would have to say it is the woman who's
being more irresponsible because the
women's are the the women are the ones
who have to allow for it to happen right
so obviously with accountability it is
always 50 50 like the 80 20 thing
applies more for like the dating Market
if that makes sense but with
accountability it is almost always both
sides but in this case it's mainly women
because as a woman like you can choose
whether you want to use protection or
not like as a woman you are the
gatekeeper to sex
right so I would have to say it's the
woman I'm bringing the child into the
world definitely because I I always I
always make this argument now people
don't usually say what if it's a
situation where the guy wants to have
the kid if the girl don't want to have
the kid it's not it's not happening bro
she's not saying so really truly when I
hear all these single moms say oh he's a
deadbeat dad oh these ain't [ __ ] bro
like no you ain't [ __ ] bro because you
picked the guy you opened your legs you
didn't protect yourself and and then
even when you ended up you know he shot
up the club or whatever after I have to
say things in a good way like that's a
good way
yeah when he shot up the club
chassis
trust me like the woman can still make a
decision like right I don't want to go
through with this I don't like him he's
a waste man you know what I'm saying so
in my opinion and I'm not saying it to
be horrible but bro a lot of these women
they could have prevented this situation
and they'll start crying because oh the
guy don't want to be involved the guy
probably bro he was probably a hookup
from hinge can I can I just you know
what I'm saying like real talk say
something as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible